the lab leak story that kovid came from
a lab apparently it's true U.S
department of energy says uh basically
that is the most likely case though
they're saying it was with low
confidence it seems yeah covid likely
leaked from a lab in China I suppose the
question is why are they now admitting
it in the government and and perhaps it
could be I don't know Casa's belly the
U.S just had a spy balloon fly overhead
there may be a conflict with China
coming and the U.S now wants to gear
public support for why there may be a
war and it actually is quite perfect I
think the reality is
Dr fauci gave funding to an organization
which then did gain of function research
at the virus Factory in Wuhan that's
what Sheamus Coughlin called it it was
good joke Sheamus the virus Factory and
then they didn't want to admit it but
we'll see we don't know Woody Harrelson
however on Saturday Night Live was uh he
made a really funny joke about how big
Pharma no I'm sorry he didn't say they
said the cartels bought up all the meat
and all the politicians and locked
everyone in their homes and they could
only leave if they did the cartels drugs
over and over and over again he's
getting a lot of heat for that